Comprehension.
Comprehension, as I've said before, is
the key to success in language learning.
It's not difficult to say something.
It's not difficult to come up
with a sentence, a limited meaning
that you want to get across.
But when you're speaking to a native
speaker who has tens of thousands of
words that they potentially could use,
many different ways of expressing the
same thought or responding to what
you have said, if you haven't got
good comprehension, you're not going
to be in the conversation very long.
You can struggle to get
your own meaning across, but you
have to have good comprehension.
How do you get good comprehension?
I think there are five concepts that
I haven't felt in my own experience
have been very useful to me.
The first one is we have to get rid of
the old idea that we have to know 95
percent of the words in any given context
in order to be able to benefit from that.
Well, first of all, I've found
that even 5% of the words, if
I don't know those
words, it's frustrating to read.
And in fact, that's what got me
going into LingQ is I had books in
Spanish and German with on every
page, you know, 10 words that I didn't
know, and I would look them up in a
dictionary and I would forget them.
So that's not that comfortable
in fact, although you get a
general sense of the meaning.
However, nowadays with online
dictionaries and with systems like
LingQ, I personally find that 10 to 15%.
Unknown words is like a sweet spot
where I'm gaining more vocabulary,
because if you are hoping to improve
your comprehension and improve your
vocabulary, if you're only dealing with
texts that have 5 percent new words,
you will take forever to increase your
vocabulary to a level where you can be
comfortable in a wide variety of contexts.
So first of all, with modern technology,
push yourself a little bit, take
advantage of online dictionaries,
take advantage of systems like LingQ.
And find your own sweet spot.
Some people might, if the subject
is very interesting, might even
accept that 20 percent unknown words.
I find that tougher, but 10 to 15
percent for me is quite comfortable.
Second of all, traditionally, if
you look at teachers approaches to
comprehension, reading comprehension,
reading strategies, you'll see
this, for example, Scarborough's
Rope, which talks about the various
aspects of comprehension.
To me, it's an unnecessary complication of
something that's pretty straightforward.
But the gist of it is that we
need prior knowledge or background
knowledge, as well as vocabulary.
And this is true.
Research has shown that front loading
vocabulary, in other words, trying
to teach, say a list of words that
the reader or the listener is about
to encounter is not as effective
as having content that the reader.
The listener is already familiar
with prior knowledge, so how do you
ensure that the reader can encounter
material that's familiar to them?
I think one of the issues there is to let
the learner, the language learner, choose
content that they want to learn about.
They have to like that content.
Traditionally, teachers like to come
up with all kinds of pre reading
strategies, asking questions and helping
the learner, the reader infer or guess.
And I think all of that is
a complete waste of time.
Rather, you can have the learner
listen to something in a classroom
that kind of primes the pump a little
bit, or you can let the learner.
Choose the content that they want
to learn from, in which case the
learner will probably choose something
that they're already familiar with.
It's interesting reading some of these
teacher's manuals about what to do.
They point out, for example, that person
of Indian origin say will find content
about something of Indian culture easier
to understand if they're learning English.
That's obviously true.
But that being the case, why is it so
often that foreign language teachers
basically try to force something that is
culturally very different, but connected
to the culture of the target language,
onto the learner at an early stage?
All of these things you
can deal with later on.
The main thing is to get the learner
engaged with the content, and in
that sense, Familiar subjects,
things they already have prior
knowledge about is far preferable.
Also, uh, in going through the sort
of various Google searches, teachers,
when they get into this sort of
pre reading, they end up trying to
direct the reader, at least in high
school classroom, wanting to make
sure that the reader or the learner.
Uh, even in sort of English as a second
language class draws the same inference.
So, you know, the inference
that aligns with the ideological
persuasion of the teacher, there's
a time and a place for everything.
And if the teacher is more interested
in promoting their ideology,
whether it be left wing or right
wing, rather than just letting the.
Reader or the learner absorb the
language and draw their own reference,
even if that inference is wrong.
It doesn't matter that you know,
interpretation of the text belongs
to the reader or the learner.
The target is to let the learner
or the reader acquire words and
acquire some familiarity with
the language, some fluency, and.
So prior knowledge, yes, but
obviously prior knowledge can only
be acquired through a lot of reading.
So the, the sort of bottom line here
is do things that will enable or
encourage the reader to read a lot.
And that brings me to the third point, and
that is we shouldn't be, again, giving the
learner comprehension questions because
we should be encouraging the reader
to accept, or the learner, to accept
the fact that they won't understand.
That a lot of what they listen to or
read in a language they're learning,
they're not going to understand it.
I sometimes call this, get
it wrong the first time.
When I worked in the lumber business, we
had this quality control program where
they said, get it right the first time.
Well, if you're manufacturing,
get it right the first time.
But if you're a language learner,
get it wrong the first time.
Keep going.
You can always come back to it.
You know, I also used once this
sort of lawnmower analogy where.
If I'm mowing the lawn and I've let the
lawn grow too long, I'm better off to,
you know, raise the level of my knives
so that I can go across the grass, you
know, cutting some of it and then come
back later on and take a second pass.
Make it easier for yourself.
Take a first pass, get a lot of stuff
wrong, maybe go off and do something
else, come back again, have a second
pass and pick up a little bit more.
We need to accept the fact that we can
get it wrong, we cannot understand it.
We don't have to answer
comprehension questions, which
I find extremely annoying.
It's enough that I have consumed a
lot of words, consumed a lot of the
language, and all of that is helping
my brain get used to the language.
You also want to sort
of come across these
Vocabulary items, words, expressions,
phrases in different contexts.
It's also been proven that more than
the sort of frequency, the sort of
repetition of the same items, which
is sometimes the case of people who,
who study lists, blocks, flashcards,
whatever, what's more important is.
To encounter the same words in
a variety of different contexts.
And that way, if it turns out the
brain is able to better retain them.
So several passes over the same content.
Be prepared not to understand,
just keep consuming the language.
However, and this is the fourth point,
you want to make it easy on yourself.
So it's, it is useful to try to
narrow the range of sort of subject
matter that you're dealing with.
And I tend to do this if I follow a
podcast, you know, on politics in say
Arabic or economics, or if I can narrow
the range of subject matter that I'm
dealing with, even if I'm dealing with
different, like I'm interleaving in the
sense that I'm dealing with different.
Podcast episodes or different sources
of content, but it's in a somewhat
narrower range of subject matter.
I'll have a higher probability of meeting
the same vocabulary over and over again.
I have then some familiarity
with the subject.
I have that prior knowledge.
If I move away, for example, from a
Political podcast to say literature or
something on an unrelated subject, having
to do with, you know, dating or something,
then it's going to be much more difficult.
So stay within the same sort
of general range of content.
And that way you're going
to achieve that goal of.
Uh, more familiar vocabulary and
some sense of prior knowledge.
And finally, a fifth point is use
the power of listening because while
reading, as I've said before, is a
great way to increase your vocabulary.
You can look words up
in an online dictionary.
You can review them.
Um, but the listening is how
I get into the subject matter.
Typically I listen first.
I'm curious.
Now I've got some sense
of what it's about.
I've got a lot of missing pieces that
I can go in and read and, uh, look up
words and get a better sense of what's
there, but the thing about listening is
that listening goes faster in most cases,
depending on where we are in the language.
But certainly for a long
time, the speed at which.
The narrator, native speaker is
speaking is faster than the speed at
which we can read in the language.
And so that means we're
getting a better, faster.
Sort of access to the content
that we're trying to read.
We have some momentum
when we start to read.
And very often, even if, if the
narrator is speaking too slowly,
in fact, it's a disadvantage.
We start to lose track by the time
we come to the end of the sentence
of what he or she was saying at
the beginning of the sentence.
So don't listen to material too slowly.
Try and force yourself to listen
to material at normal speed.
In fact, I sometimes crank
up the speed at LingQ.
In order to listen to it more quickly,
I can cover the material more quickly.
And I find I get a, in some ways
a better, almost like a bird's eye
view of what I'm listening to by the
mere fact that it's going faster.
And in fact, I did mention in a previous
video that There was this dyslexic
person, whose name now escapes me, who
developed a methodology of, you know,
listening at two or three times normal
speed in order to overcome his dyslexia.
So there is some advantage in forcing
yourself to listen and to listen quickly.
And of course, to listen a lot, to build
up your momentum and your comprehension
skills for when you go into reading.
So in summary.
I've given you five strategies for
improved comprehension, both reading
comprehension and listening comprehension.
This is the key.
This is the base for your
progress in the language.
Once you have good comprehension, you
can work on refining bits of grammar.
You can work on improving your output, but
the key is to get that good comprehension.
And one important element is for
you to believe in yourself and
for you to trust the process.
If you keep on doing these things, if
you keep on consuming the language,
you will achieve your goals.
So, thank you for listening, and I have
spoken before on comprehension, so you
might want to check out these other
videos that I did on the same subject.
Bye for now.